eigentlich will sich deutschland locker
machen aber einer wand vom locker lassen
karl lauterbach dem
bundesgesundheitsminister gehen viele
schritte zu weit er mahnt jetzt
politisch nicht kurzsichtig zu sein
wenn ich ehrlich sagen so ist es so dass
ich davon ausgehe dass sie noch sehr
lange mit der pandemie zu tun haben
werden
da kann man wirklich in zeiträumen auch
vor zehn jahren die nächste welle im
herbst wird kommen nicht nur lauterbach
ist sich da sicher anspruch war immer
besser vorbereitet zu sein doch von
welle zu welle träten die gleichen grund
probleme auf beispiel schule eltern
lehrer und schüler fühlen sich und
werden allein gelassen regel würde
erhebliche defizite bei der
digitalisierung keine vorausschauende
planung auch der expertenrat der
bundesregierung fordert eindringlich in
seiner jüngsten stellungnahme mehr auf
das kindeswohl zu schauen
besonders schwerwiegend ist die
sekundäre krankheitslast durch
psychische und physische erkrankungen
wie angst krankheit tod oder existenz
verlust
hört schon mehrfach geheißen licht am
ende des tunnels aber es hat sich immer
wieder dann anders herausgestellt viele
versprechungen sind nicht gehalten
worden insofern ist das vertrauen in die
politik man wird sicher durch die
schulen geführt die schulen sind sicher
der immer behauptet worden dieses
vertrauen ist sehr löchrig und hat
deutlich nachgelassen beispiel
digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen
politik agiert weiter auf unsicherer
datenbasis die importe ist ungenau die
vernetzung ist unzureichend auch hier
geht der expertenrat mit der vergangenen
und der jetzigen regierung hart ins
gericht auch zwei jahre nach beginn der
pandemie in deutschland besteht
weiterhin keinen zugang zu einigen
wichtigen aktuellen versorgungs daten
ich glaube wir müssen uns diesem thema
wirklich ganz intensiv widmen für den
herbst und winter dieses jahres
und dazu gehört vor allen dingen auch
dass wir endlich wissen müssen wie viele
krankenhausbetten es gibt wie viele
davon belegt sind wie viele frei sind
wie cobit patienten wir haben und was
mir am allerwichtigsten ist wie viele
pflegekräfte arbeit da eigentlich in den
krankenhäusern es fehlte überblick sagt
auch der experte für digitale medizin
philipp staffel muss deutschen und
platzierte sich beim datenschutz und bei
den zuständigkeiten
wir sind glaube ich auch im
internationalen vergleich im vergleich
mit einigen europäischen ländern auf
jeden fall sehr weit hinten wir haben
nicht die möglichkeit
zwischen den sogenannten
leistungserbringern also ärzten
krankenhäusern und auf vielen anderen
beteiligten im gesundheitswesen und
digital überhaupt auszutauschen also wir
können keine daten hin und her versenden
wir haben keine strukturierten sicheren
wege dafür
streitfall allgemeine impfpflicht die
regierung ist uneins hat keine eigene
ampel mehrheit hat die frage zur
gewissensentscheidung erklärt einigen
sehen die impfpflicht als garant für
einen sicheren herbst andere vor allem
in der fdp halten sie für
unverhältnismäßig wir sollten unsere
energien auf praktikable und
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen konzentrieren
und nicht auf eine impfpflicht die
schwer umsetzbar ist und mehr
gesellschaftliche verwerfungen schafft
wenn wir aus dieser pandemie
herauskommen wollen wenn wir die
freiheit zurück haben wollen und
verlässlich auf freiheit halten und
erreichen wollen dann gelingt es nur mit
einer allgemeine impfpflicht
weiterer streit fall der sogenannte
basisschutz am 20 märz entfällt die
rechtsgrundlage für die korona maßnahmen
viele länder fordern einen gesetzlichen
rahmen darüber hinaus olaf scholz bleibt
unkonkret die fdp bremst und die
opposition sieht die offene flanke des
kanzlers er hat ausdrücklich gesagt er
will sich dafür einsetzen hat aber auch
gesagt er könne nicht für seine
regierung sprechen
oder was war jetzt nicht drumrumreden
das weiß doch jeder bus problem liegt
jeder weiß wo das problem liegt und
diese koalition muss sich entscheiden ob
sie zu irgend einer gemeinsamen position
kommt bouffier meint das problem seien
die liberalen den kampf gegen die krone
pandemie beschreibt der
bundesgesundheitsminister als marathon
der streit um die allgemeine impfpflicht
und den basisschutz zeigt aber dass sich
die regierung gerade nicht auf eine
gemeinsame laufrichtung einigen kann